it's mommy's first day back to the
office this week i don't want you to go
don't go
they're not brave like you
that's too scared to do
anything that's different anything
wow
uh is it for your golf trophies it's for
you
they're turning your book into a movie i
wish i felt less itchy about it make the
most of this i don't understand why you
guys aren't answering any of my
questions
you're not saying anything
there's a lot of photos missing i hate
them well
got married without even knowing what it
would be like you could return him
and what's the reason for returning your
husband where to
[Music]
[Music]
who start do this
i'm a ghost
it's annoying that you're actually kind
of attractive
you want to take revenge like a man you
gotta dress like one
or not take revenge is the other option
i met someone oh my god is he married no
do you want dessert
[Music]
i will do bedtime that's a risky move
promising bedtime
i really don't know how you ladies do it
oh
witchcraft made
oh if me am a ghost why am i still
getting cramps
you